Greetings from Electro Mejía with his Spanish-language news network The
Southern Nevada Health District is
planning to open another site to give
official vaccinations They are working to
possibly use the
convention center as the second
largest vaccination site Appointments for this
future site  They will be available as
of February 1 and they hope to
open it on February 2. So far,
this center will only accept appointments for
people who received the first dose
of the vaccine at the Question High
School El Carmen Center or the
Teachers' Health District Office.  o
Clark County School District staff members
can now sign up for the
vaccine,
a page run by the
University of Las Vegas' launched
Tuesday asking educators to
fill out a form indicating
their position with the  district will
then be notified on how to
make an appointment to receive the vaccine
today  Learn more about the fire that
consumed an apartment complex that
was under construction in the southwest
valley last week. The fire
destroyed more than 200 units in the
complex and
another small tactile nearby apartments also caused
$25-35 million in  damage the
clark county fire department along with federal investigators
revealed that the fire was started at a
construction site
70 years ago today the first
atomic bomb test was made at the
nevada bomb test site an
air force plane  of the country dropped a
bomb in an area known as fragment
flatts northwest of las vegas it was the
first of more than 900 atomic tests
that have been carried out in the state for more
than 41 years
and in terms of weather the clouds will
remain over the valley with the
possibility  of more rain today and the rest
of the week the sun will return on Saturday
and thus the temperatures will also begin to warm up
for the week  na that comes
have a nice day greets héctor
mejía with initiated in spanish
[Music]